what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and let's get this video
to 2 000 likes that's the most important
metric that YouTube uses to push out
these streams also guys if you want to
support the channel and the audacity
Network make sure you get yourself a
women's shouldn't vote t-shirt today
there are new studies coming out showing
that if women did not vote Republicans
would have won for the last 50 years
imagine that
only Republicans for the last 50 years
what a world what an amazing time so if
you guys want to be in a world like that
make sure you get yourself a women's
shouldn't vote t-shirt people will come
up to you left and right talking about
how awesome you are
okay guys so I want to tell you a story
now about in the last month I was
reached out to by a reporter
and this reporter came up to me and she
asked me
to take part in her doc documentary
about me called the rise of pearl Davis
I'm like wow
the rise at like that sounds like
like that sounds like evil it's like the
rise of anti-Semitism or the rise of
racism I'm like what are they what are
they putting about me in this
documentary so you know
I just kind of leave her on scene I'm a
busy gal you know what I mean I got left
and right collaborations requests all
this stuff so I'm like I am a busy chica
so you know then
she messages me again and says well
we're doing the documentary with or
without you and I'm like
wow
that's so crazy and you know I I wonder
I think I haven't gotten as much of
pushback because I'm a chick to be
honest you know I think if I was a guy
by now I'd have some sexual assault
allegations or or something they would
just throw at me because I'm a chick
and the reason that I say this is
because I see people that get closer and
closer to the truth like Russell Brandt
where they seemingly destroy this man's
reputation without a trial and you see
people reaching out to Media networks to
essentially destroy him calling him a
rapist
um saying that he has assaulted women
going to all of his axes you saw that
happen with the Tates and in recent news
Dave portnoyd caught wind that they were
planning an attack on him
um so Dave actually got ahead of it and
he called the Washington balls about
riding a hit piece on him so let's pull
up the clip
disassembly hey Emily this is Dave
Portnoy calling uh I'm recording you
right now but I've noticed a bunch of
people you it seems like you're sending
we have this pizza Fest happening on
Saturday and you're reaching out to our
advertisers and you're basically sending
an email that says to the effect Dave's
a misogenic racist do you want to defend
yourselves advertising at this event
right
I'm sorry what's your name Dave I'm
sorry who are you I'm the guy you're
writing the article about Dave Portland
Portland oh hey how are you good
good no I'm not I'm not I haven't said
anything like that well I I can I can
read
if you want
if you want I can read what you actually
sent I have it yeah yeah me because I
sent a bunch of notes so I want to make
sure I know which one okay uh we are
planning to write about the festival and
how and how some of the sponsors and
participants have drawn criticism by
seemingly to associate themselves with
Dave Portnoy who has a history of
misogenic comments and other problematic
Behavior I want to make sure that blank
had a chance to respond to this since
the company is the most prominent in
their partners of his Festival oh that's
the one I sent to which was definitely
the most pointed of them because I
really did want them to respond and I
was hoping to get something from them do
you think that's fair like I I totally
disagree with the assertions of what you
said that misogenic and all that stuff
so like it kind of backs people into a
corner so I'm happy to go over anything
I mean you have that is pretty pointed
you said you didn't do it then I have
the exact evidence of you doing it so I
didn't say I didn't do that I said I did
that was the one that was the most well
no you that before I before I provided
proof you said you didn't really
remember doing that and then I read it
to you and you're like oh yeah I did it
that one time so you did do it
um I'm happy to talk about the comments
because to me it's kind of like torture
interference like we're doing an event
everyone's happy about the event uh you
know I've raid 50 million for small
business I've held pizzas none of that
it's Dave's misogenic and problematic
and I'm happy to talk about it because
to me nobody would like if someone's
going around sending that email to their
Spa sponsors and again you're not like
questioning you you're it's almost like
a statement of fact this is what I am at
the same time you're saying you don't
know that that's actually truth so
you're you're leading with something
that you haven't done enough research to
know if it's valid and I'm saying there
might be a fuller picture and that's
what I want to talk to you about and I
want to set up a time tomorrow morning
baby
like 10 are you free at 10
. I gotta do more research on you I I
still don't have the vibe that you're
good like that you're going to give me
any sort of fair Shake
yeah I was hilarious
and I'm telling you guys this is what
these just do and feminine men it's like
the chicks in the simps the chicks and
The Sims
um they're already calling him
misogynistic before they've even talked
to him and that's why guys they can't
throw that at me what are you gonna say
I'm a misogynist
what do I hate myself I'm a woman I'm a
woman
this is what he says it's called slander
well libel since it is in writing if any
of his sponsors back out and get similar
messages he has a lawsuit she openly
admitted she made it up good point
traditional journalism is dead
defamation lawsuit legit disgusting
unreal this is so unfair and this is the
thing guys we are in a point in history
where we can't even trust journalists
and it's because all these chicks they
hit you with misogynistic racist sexist
whatever they're gonna throw at you that
day
um whenever they want to assassinate
your character they'll look for anything
bad that you've said ever which I'm
sorry guys if you had hours and hours
and hours and hours of content of you
talking you don't think you'll have
anything you can take out of context
really I really do think it's good he
got ahead of it and guys like this are
actually speaking out about really uh
the attack that journalism does on men
it's mostly men that get hit with this
it's misogynistic sexual assault rape
abuse whatever they can throw at them
you know and then they report it to fame
him without any evidence
um okay so a realization I had
is in society there's really three
groups of guys
there are the Chads
the simps and the sexless and this is
how I'm gonna divide it now the Chads
typically are the guys that Bang all the
chicks and I've always said that the
Chads have the most honest view of women
because the Chads are the best looking
most successful guys that they've seen
the worst of women they've seen wives
cheat on their husbands with them
they've they've seen women that you
would think are good girls go home with
them on the first night so it's
interesting if you talk to a guy that
gets laid a lot or just has been with a
[__] ton of women he just has a really
different view then you have the simps
now
I'm not saying every guy in this
category is a simp there is some overlap
where like some guys are like kind of in
between where they'll simp for one girl
and be a Chad for another so there's
some overlap but we're just gonna talk
in generalities okay now the next group
are the men that marry Chad's leftovers
and they'll they'll typically put women
on a pedestal they'll say things like
let me ask my wife because to them the
women are above them the women have this
amazing feminine and you can get it's
more of a mindset than anything but the
the women are just so awesome and
amazing and so special and you should
just cherish them for a lifetime where
the Chads are like they're just chicks
what do you what are you what are you
doing
um and then there's the sexless who
really just aren't even a part of the
game women don't give them a time of day
and they always talk about the incels
like the sexless men being so angry and
that's just not really my experience you
know I think of anything the guys that
get I don't even want to say angry but
like
more are a bit more blunt when talking
about women take them off of the
pedestal it tends to be the Chads
because they've seen the worst an incel
is never going to see the worst of women
well okay let me explain let me actually
go back and incel will see the worst of
women in the fact that he'll see women
be especially rude to him but in terms
of like I guess [__] Behavior I would
say the Chads see the worst of it the
incels don't really get to interact with
women because really most women kind of
treat them like they're invisible and
the the simps are the guys that kind of
have to drunk through hoops so they
think you have to court a girl do all
the traditional stuff to get sex and
relationships the Chads know they don't
really got to do too much okay and it's
interesting because I saw this on
Twitter and this has just been my
experience from talking to Ben
so I I've done uh like two years of
shows now
um so I wanna I wanna give you guys a
little background to like I guess my
research into this what what my world
view comes from so
I started with more of a traditional
conservative point of view that's where
I started
um I grew up watching The Daily wire Ben
Shapiro Candace Owens love them still do
awesome awesome content creators
um but I started off reacting to like
pickup videos so it would be all these
videos from guys learning how to get
laid I just thought it was so
interesting to hear these like tricks
they would do or like how they built
attraction so far so I went to like a
pickup artist conference so I did this
for like a year in my free time I would
just do reaction videos okay then I
started a show and I always felt like
you know at that point I was like okay a
lot of these guys are a bit dramatic
women aren't so bad you know like not
all women are like that until I did a
show okay
and I interviewed
guys I can't even tell you how much this
changes your world view I interviewed
hundreds of men and women
I think we have over 700 guests logged
that have been to this studio
um on top of that I started doing a
divorce documentary and you know
interviewing the guys that get laid and
interviewing the men that have been
screwed by divorce
has made me had a completely different
point of view of women
because what I found out was that
the guys that get screwed over in
divorced tend to be the simp category
where they think women are these awesome
Angels they're just they could never do
no wrong all you have to do is find a
good woman and treat her well and you'll
have a good life
and those are the ones that I I just saw
getting screwed over in divorced it
wasn't the rich guys
um it wasn't the in cells it was the guy
the traditional men that wanted to get
married semi young usually in their 20s
and have a good life
and what would happen is they would
trust a woman
she would say she was on birth control
and no it was not always baby mothers no
it was not women with that tattoos they
are normal women that you meet and a lot
of these women would trap men in
marriage and relationships or they would
get married they would do it the right
way and
um after she got the kids that she
wanted she would just change it was
interesting because I was scrolling
through Twitter and I saw something that
sort of backed up what I saw in the real
world
Rolf Deegan all right contrary to
popular belief it is the sexually busy
Chads not the sexually desperate and
frustrated incels who have the most
misogynistic worldview
so it says we asked whether a mismatch
between sexual intentions how many
sexual partners a person would like to
have an actual sexual practice how many
sexual partners a person had predicts
extreme misogynistic views which you
know it's like how do you how do you
measure what what is misogynistic but
whatever
so contrary to the incel narrative we do
not find support for this overall claim
um rather extreme misogynistic views are
driven by a psychology of status seeking
and dominance orientation which
correlates with having many not few
sexual partners the individuals we
crudely categorized as in cells in our
sample are characterized by lower levels
of misogyny need for chaos social
dominance orientation psychopathy
narcissism
machiavellianism and acceptance of
violence than the rest of the sample
further the incels opposite the Chads
the archetypal alpha males who is
socially dominant and successful in
finding romantic and sexual partners
appear to have the most extreme
misogynistic views in our samples Chad's
numerous sexual conquests are linked to
an objectified view of women that
degrades women to game them for which
males compete so it's interesting
because this is also something I
witnessed in the shows the guys that
actually pissed the women off the most
would have the women hitting on them
after
you know and you just kind of see more
behind the scenes and I bet you fresh
and fit whatever podcast they could all
attest to this it's like it's weird the
men that the women like hate the most
are the ones they show the most
attention to
I think indifference I think hatred for
a guy is much better than indifference
if a girl's indifferent then she doesn't
care you know women we just have a
tendency towards chaos men have a
tendency towards order
and for whatever reason what I see is
women are much more willing to adopt
absolutely batshit crazy social trends
um so for example
the trans movement is 80 women so a lot
of times we see these men invading
women's spaces but we never talk about
the women invading the men's spaces
because it's mostly women invading the
men's space
um but on national TV let's see what
these super logical chicks are arguing
transgender boys who might not have
their own money to go by tampons if
they're provided free in the bathroom
it's it's a huge plus men do not
menstruate only women men straight now
you can call yourself whatever you want
straight but trans men do menstrual
non-binary people demonstrating is not
exclusive yes it's women no it's not yes
it is
if your chromosomes are xx and you're
young you're menstruate if you're XY you
don't correct but what about trans men
and non we're not getting a whole group
of their women dressed as men you are
not a man you pretend to be a man and
that's okay that's perfectly fine live
your life tell me what a man is well
what's a man to you you define a man for
me you have chromosomes that are X and Y
that's what a man is so why are we just
looking at the the the the science of
this as a design when when we've learned
sex and gender identity a two very the
completely different things they're not
completely they are completely different
completely different words and sex is
what you're born with the sexual
reproductive organs you have gender is
what you identify with I don't accept
that distinction you have to argue for
it you're just giving a conclusion
you're you're just making it up
foreign
you see him and like this is what I mean
this is traditional masculinity and this
is the problem women have co-signed
these stupid ideas for too long and then
you get these symptoms men that co-sign
them too this is true masculinity
telling the women that they're deluded
this is crazy and
it's unfortunate because a lot of men
will lose their jobs and have the Matrix
come after them simply because they
State their opinion which is much more
likely to be rooted in fact than women
I'll tell you in my lifetime so I'm 26
right and I remember going to college I
was 17 when I went to college this was
like 10 years ago so I remember when
Bruce Jenner got the female courage
award
and that was the first time that really
we saw transgenderism on the world stage
and at this point um I didn't really
like it but I just didn't care you know
what I mean I was playing volleyball I
was I was doing other stuff I was busy
so I just didn't pay that close of
attention to it I was just like whatever
who cares
but I actually regret not speaking out
about it more because that was the
beginning
of the end of women's sports
you know now it's 10 years later I in my
lifetime I've seen a man compete
in a woman's swimming competition and
take her medal I you know I've also
actually gone to a volleyball tournament
where there's almost an entire group of
men playing
and be reprimanded by that Organization
for talking about it for interviewing
people and asking what they think
um and this is all in my lifetime and
it's so it's so sad to see how like
something starts and how it is now
um you know and I I would argue that
it's a Eugenics movement what you see is
that the typical trans person is
actually an autistic girl
think about that guys
they're sterilizing they're essentially
sterilizing autistic people
by giving them a sense of community and
family and making them think that the
solution to all of their problems is to
become a boy
and then on top of that they're allowing
predatory men into our locker rooms no I
don't want to share a locker room with a
guy no I don't want to compete with a
guy no
um I think I've played volleyball for I
don't know 16 years now I started
playing when I was 10. I cannot compete
with a man I am six foot I am taller
than most men yet a guy shorter than me
can lift more than me and jump higher
than me it doesn't matter we're built
different we're not the same I can never
bench what a guy benches I cannot do
what a man can do it doesn't matter if
I'm a tomboy it doesn't matter if I'm
strong I cannot do what a man can do and
so we need to stop with this media
movement of turning women into men and
men into women and what we're seeing
more and more is really just a mental
health crisis in this country you know
when you have an entire generation of
people that grew up with fighting
parents single mother homes and really a
gender War
I mean that's what it is a war on men
um you you really do get mental
disorders you know
um a couple weeks ago maybe a couple
months ago now
um I was with I was with blessing in
America and you know we had a flight
um to go I think it was from LA to Vegas
no no it was vague it was Vegas to
Chicago and so we were late to the
airport and we were trying to make this
flight and we missed this flight by 10
minutes guys
and you know it was our own fault we
left late whatever
um
so then we had to wait we knew we had to
wait for the next flight which was like
four hours but whatever it happens we
weren't pressed
um next to us there was a girl that
actually also missed her flight
this girl guys I never thought I never
thought I would see this in person this
chick
laid on the floor and started screaming
now guys I've I've this day I didn't
know Betty where to be so I was fine
um I felt like that before okay I've had
that thought there have been times where
I've this isn't my first flight I've
missed shocking I know where I I
understand the feeling but she was like
20 something and this grown ass lady
was crying on the floor
and
um I just I just couldn't believe it I
was I was like and it's funny because a
lot of times what they'll say is social
media isn't real life and you know what
I'll say at first it's not so 10 years
ago when I saw Caitlyn Jenner on the
screen of my TV that wasn't real life
but now it's 10 years later and
tournaments that I play in and my little
sisters now because they're in sports
it becomes real life so it might not
start off as real life but what happens
is a lot of these Trends start in the
cities you might be in the suburbs or
the country and slowly but surely they
come to you
you know um just because you want to
walk away from the craziness that's
going on it doesn't protect your kids
from it it doesn't protect the schools
from it
unless you become literally Amish
um so now I'm in the airport this lady's
like screaming on the floor and we go to
rebook the flight she's like yelling at
the at the flight attendant I swear I
looked at her and I was like
this is your own fault because she was
she was literally trying to blame she
was trying to blame the flight
attendants because the plane they closed
the doors like five minutes before the
flight opened or whatever and she got
there like right as the flight is
supposed to take off and I'm thinking
this lady's freaking nuts it's your own
fault then get there or you know what I
mean like you know I I missed it too I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna cry
but you see these people with a mental
like literally mental disorders and
another phenomenon that I see just from
interviewing women after women after
women
is really these chicks having mental
disorders
um to the point where you interview
women on the street you say rate
yourself one to ten they say ten why do
they think that because the attention
they're getting is the level of a 10 10
years ago we get so much attention from
Instagram
um the likes we edit our pictures we
literally think we look different and
it's so interesting because they come on
the show and sometimes I'll follow them
after the show I don't know I'm a nice
I'm a nice gal occasionally and
it's so crazy sometimes I don't even
recognize them
so there is an Instagram famous model
that a meltdown on a plane when she says
she left to avoid knocking seat mate the
F out let's pull it up call me a [__]
again yeah you guys did nothing wrong no
you shut the [__] up you shut the [__]
up in your [__]
film me I'm Instagram famous
how many social media commentators these
Instagram [__] are broke
they're literally oh so she's an only
fans model
wow of course
of course I'm shocked
and so do you see this delusion now
she's she thinks she's so important
because she sells her ass pictures and
the thing is you got about a 10-year
shelf life and then you're done
if you're not insightful if you're not
smart there's nothing you're just done
in the in the especially if all you're
selling is sex good luck okay they said
so what do you do I'm a model on
Instagram you I'm a soldier on Call of
Duty
wow wow
and you know this this is delusion and
it's so interesting because I see this
like culture and my mom and my dad just
always told me and I'm not saying I'm
perfect at this but for the most part
like no matter what people are doing to
you like just stay calm like the person
that first gets a rise out of you
they're they lost you lose
and you know it's so interesting because
people get like they always it's always
over like disrespect and the thing is
people are so soft when it comes to like
people just take freaking everything as
disrespect
yeah but you know it's so interesting
because these this stuff really does
start just online you think oh it's not
real life
wait five years
wait 10 years
wait your kids are going to talk to
these people you know
um
so
as I talked about earlier I really do
see I do see three types of men the
Chads the simps and the sexless all
right and I I see two phenomenons going
on
um one is the simps will do more and
more and more to get these women you see
them buying extravagant Rings just doing
the most is to get these chicks and you
see the Chads realizing how much
leverage they have and just doing the
wildest [__] I'm going to give you an
example so this girl talks about my date
invited two more women to dinner to find
the perfect three-way
I just had the worst first date of my
life I figure I'm just gonna tell you
what happened and then we're gonna try
and work our way back from there
my date invited myself along with two
other women so that he could speed up
the process of finding his perfect
three-way I met this guy on a dating app
and I feel like by all reasonable
measures he was pretty much just your
average guy literally nothing in his
profile could have prepared me for what
was to come he agreed to meet at this
Italian restaurant that's about 15
minutes away from my house so I show up
in my Uber and I'm probably like 10
minutes early because I'm usually I just
usually show up early to things I don't
know when I get there he's standing
outside the restaurant and I recognize
him from his profile so at least he's
not a catfish you know we say hi to each
other and then he's just like okay let's
go inside and grab our table
he made a reservation so the table was
ready right when we got there so at
least that was nice they bring us to a
table and they seat us at this four top
which honestly isn't that weird if you
think about it we're really only sitting
there for like maybe two minutes before
this girl walks up who I think at the
time is just the waitress but no no and
you already know what's coming she kind
of just looks at me funny and then
introduces herself just casually and I'm
like oh hi like I'm Megan and as she's
sitting down the next girl walks up so
all the girls are just introducing each
other and I'm like what the [__] is
going on he's just sitting there like
completely [__] fine and then she
goes oh so like how do you know so and
so as in the guy I'm just not gonna say
his name because honestly you know I
should [__] say his name Matthew it
was Matthew and I'm like oh I actually
don't really this is our first date so
naturally my next question is oh well
how do you know Matthew he looks me dead
in the eyes and goes I thought this was
our first date
yeah I just thought that these other two
girls were friends that he knew that
were around maybe he invited I don't
know people are weird but no he'd
scheduled this day at the same time with
all three of us to meet at this place
and why you might ask well you're
probably not asking because I already
told you he was trying to speed up his
process of finding the perfect three-way
we all left
okay I wanna I wanna give you guys some
context so
if this guy on dating apps women only
initiate contact five percent of the
time they only match it's like 15 to 20
percent of men are getting all the
swipes so this is a guy already she
might think he's average but women were
deluded we don't know that we find 80
percent of men is ugly mind you so when
they say average guy this means he's
probably still in the top 10 percent of
guys so if he's able to get three dates
that tells me in terms of dating app
stats he's up there
so
um this is straight Savage I
I wish they could have recorded this
that is so funny so this guy now I'm not
saying this is right I'm not saying you
you should do that but you kind of
Wonder like it it
if he's doing it it had to have worked
at least once
right
right like
um so
what I see really is the top ten five
percent of men they're just doing
crazier and crazier stuff I mean you
have Andrew Tate right he's openly
saying he wants multiple to have
children with multiple women same with
his brother
and women are you you see women getting
more desperate for the top 10 percent of
men and so they agree to it they just
say okay I'll do it and this kind of
goes to a lesson now I know it didn't
work out for this guy but what this
tells me is that if he's doing it it's
probably worked once
it's probably worked once so what what
you start to get is um
women would rather be the king's
concubine than the peasant's wife I
don't say this in a happy way but the
last couple hundred of years the top 15
percent of men have always had
concubines they've always have multiple
women there's a reason King Solomon had
like 300 wives
um yeah and this is why I say you know
if you date the top 15 percent of men
don't be shocked
if they're someone else and the solution
is don't if you don't want that then
don't date the top 15 percent of men
pick your poison but the problem is
women just want it all they want
everything
and
um Are there women that win the lottery
and get everything yes
but don't count on it do you know what I
mean like what are we gonna count on
this you can hope for it you know hope
for the best but you know this goes back
to women we're just not the most logical
we don't look at dating and think well
it's probably better to have the normal
guy than share the top guy no it's just
based on how we feel well I feel a
certain way with him therefore this is
what I'm going for I don't I I don't
make the rules I just tell you what they
are so I was scrolling on Twitter guys
Pearl's just a Mac I'm an expert tweeter
and it says reminder the projected
results for the 2018 midterms based on
polling patterns and 50 38's life
forecast on October October 24th so this
is showing what would happen
if women didn't vote
look at that how beautiful is that map
how guys and get your women to vote
t-shirt today all right repeal it take
that [__] away so
someone tweeted only MTF transgenders
would promote this or only weak women
repeal the 19th
so I just introduce myself I say why
hello there I'm Pearl
get yourself a win and shoot a vote
t-shirt today guys all the craziness
everything we talked about today who was
writing the hit piece on Dave portnoid
women
um you know who
who was arguing for the trans stuff
women
um who is freaking out on the plane
women there is there's a natural order
in the world that goes God men women
children and when we mess up the natural
order of the world and give authority to
women and not men [__] gets [__] up
don't shoot the messenger guys have a
great weekend get yourself a women's in
about t-shirt like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel I'll talk
to you next time